yeah welcome to this video playing
Yevgenia which again platon just two
games before I think spoiling a
completely winning end game see what
what happens now Queens gambit with
Bishop f4 and he's playing with b6 which
is an interesting line so one of the
more fighting choices it's difficult for
black to get some mum fight and discern
this type of position v6 is some one of
the possibilities ok I just played
Bishop d3 not caring about the loss of
Temple just keep my development going
here ok I said tending maybe b5 and c5
the question is is there something to to
worry or should I play a form could play
a form now what I prefer to do that just
speeding up development the question is
to be three or d three yeah maybe him
like to keep the the Defiant see file
open
very quickly played
k rookie one is probably a good move
anyway so night 95 or is there something
else came by centralizing should be okay
now let's um let's let's consider how to
learn to activate look see one maybe
just from see one
maybe I should have taken myself I'm not
sure yeah that's let's take think it's a
good thing to get his 92 127
I don't think I don't think he could
avoid before now i have fun no i have
from a good square on sea foam and a
very good Bishop p.m. 92 to see for some
the next step haha maybe 94 yeah anyway
mouth I'll pin this so should I just
take on I don't know g5 and I think this
is a good a good way to to exchange
yeah I didn't really pay attention to
Queen g6 which is which is a shame
really it's quite an obvious move I did
good one fan I really support that not
saying that I'm I was better or
something but this was certainly not the
the best possible result and can
hmm b2 is just just hanging never put
the night is he fine
yeah what a move trying to block the CFL
for the moment just a very ugly position
prepare f3
yeah maybe it is some it is still a
willing form for the moment but it's
very very ugly chest yeah he wants to
play book Brooke age four and then
sacrifice we can't want to go here
anyway
Wow yeah but this isn't working at all
Wow hooks if I didn't see any of that
okay so maybe this is just great what
he's doing I've had time to even
understand what it is doing if i take
here what is happening Queenie for even
know what point you for 593 and Bishop
Bishop takes Queen to what I don't
understand any of that okay let's see
what he's doing Queen takes okay blood
it's very dangerous anyway even if
there's no no immediate knock out the
ship takes hmm now it's um it's mate how
to how to defend that this one giving up
this
cannot take no cause of rook c8 Queen
each form yeah this is this is already
good good for good for me just an
exchange up more or less time morning
but it's 7 20 seconds
check yeah it's i'm down on eight
seconds this is the problem
now I played this excellently but then
just blundered it away but it's it
doesn't matter simply because it's a
it's a it's a nonsensical time control
but what what can you do Jack White
modules whole time yeah okay but of
course he had completely outplayed me
around here it was very ugly but him
yeah this this was of course a shocking
move it wasn't really necessary it could
could play em player just normal moves
in fact that the computer points out a
tactical win can take him yeah very
strong instead he played this this
shotgun I am really cool and maybe I
should go nigh g3 and I saw this
movement okay this isn't entirely
winning from black black is doing well
but yeah here of course it can play this
is much much stronger so what I expected
and after that i'm basically yeah i'm
just winning for nothing but okay at
some it's 20 seconds against one minute
20 and you don't need to make any good
moves anymore only way for me would be
to get a quick quick major in but his
king is quite secure so um this isn't
possible to do and i'm not gonna come
where I cannot make it 17 seconds so
many great moves here should really play
that one get the a pawn yeah okay but
what can you do I was just playing too
slowly while I was under such pressure
this is this starting here I really
played the plate this badly here I
probably had this is just just just just
very bad I need to I need to play a
Knight f3 or something this is the I
need to do this it still should be quite
okay for me I always I have have pretty
pretty good pieces so when I shouldn't
be in bad shape alright thanks for
watching